omma condensed milk giggles bill school
all my condensed milk and a biscuit how
much alcohol is in this because I want
to get turnt it's refreshing just to
look at it yeah it's just gorgeous all
right what are they saying South Africa
- cheers Cheers
this is very good this is fine whatever
damn bitters and juice it's like
drinking a soft gust of air if you told
me I was drinking alcohol right now I
believe I would - and I'd get fake drunk
- biltong looks like cool bacon it's
like stained glass of meat when your
fingers get really like shriveled from
water this is what they feel like okay I
see all this it's hard to get through it
tastes like it's big what is that big
enjoy everybody bake it make it bigger
make it big it's like you setup to like
make some jerky but after like a day you
get impatient and so you're just like
yeah that's good enough
pecs and Joe Vette know why so they're
only girl anchovies in there thank God
it smells like what they would feed
penguins oh this bread was so good until
now I like that mmm I don't well just
feels and tastes like pate when do they
eat this when children have been naughty
a bunch of fish washed up on a beach and
then rotted there for a couple days and
then we just ate the sand underneath
that hill chards and or mackerel and or
anchovies lot of endures and yeah so he
definitely just ate some dolphins
rust that sounds so good the old Baker
woman who's just up to no good
that's what I imagine like a prettier
version of the witch who ate Hansel and
Gretel it sort of looks like Diglett
like the pokemons this is the evolved
form of Diglett smells like those
crackers you get it at the pediatrician
one like you were good maybe like here's
a delicious cracker someone had
insurance Cheers
holy smokes you gotta have a bite to eat
this you have to have teeth I would like
to like break this up and crumble it
over like some ice cream oh no I feel
like I'm gonna eat this under
circumstance but if I had a choice that
wouldn't be like give me the Oma's this
looks like what everything we ate
becomes it looks like a giant Slim Jim
all right just like I said just be like
a damn there's like sausage that your
grandpa forgot about Oh tree bark
exterior nice Moss interior well what's
that flavor well you eat this up you put
some ketchup on it maybe some mustard
and a bun Oh feel like a pretzel bun put
some ancho that on it oh I wouldn't do
that right off the bat these remind me
of like flotsam and jetsam
Ursula's little eel friends is it fried
it smells like anything that's right
finally these are even better than you
rusks dog food I never and rate up dog
food this is wonderful one everyone
loves dough I like it either dough boy I
would I feel like everything we ate was
something you eat when you're
exceptionally drunk every single South
African food is amazing it's so good at
it it's this is a miracle